bonjour et bienvenue à la conférence de
presse de thor le monde des ténèbres
un film signé à l'extérieur et sans plus
attendre je vous demande d'accueillir le
président de mardan studieuse et
producteur du film qui avait une faille
guy qui est ici pour nous
exceptionnellement wine travel natalie
portman james cameron
la quille et bien sûr l'aspect dedans tu
lis le réalisateur alan tales of it into
you vdn of might and magic universe je
voulais simplement demandé tout d'abord
à kevin failli en quel sens thor le
monde des ténèbres entre est il
complètement dans sa vision de l'univers
cinématique de marvel alors là c'est
vrai que c'est le deuxième film dans ce
que j'appelle la phase 2 c'est-à-dire la
phase qui commence après les ventures
qui montrent en réalité pour moi
l'importance de montrer que le héros
individuel est aussi intéressant pris
individuellement que lorsqu'on parle
évidemment d'un groupe de super héros et
je crois que nous l'avons montré avec le
premier film du genre la phase 2 qui est
évidemment cet été
iron iii et
et à l'entendre ici présents évidemment
est complètement dans le moule de ce que
je voulais pour ce film a coaché you
guys première question ici à lolo oui ça
marche
une question pour nathalie je veux
savoir quelle émotion particulière
c'était de présenter cette suite à paris
pour une presque parisienne est par
ailleurs vous êtes vous avez un
calendrier de l'actrice extrêmement
chargée en même temps vous êtes diplômé
de psychologie engagés dans des
associations vous êtes maman comment
vous arrivez à tout mener de front
les malinois for you to begin paris 16e
on est à l'origine du mal joué au baiser
car l'un d'eux à une coordination eau
ce fps comme alors c'est vrai que
d'abord merci c'est vrai que pour moi
c'était tout à fait un moment spécial
puisque ma première avant-première je
les fait à paris lorsque j'avais 12 ans
c'était pour léon et je me souviens avec
jean reno et besson à la fin du film on
est apparu comme ça derrière les rideaux
donc le public hurlait un peu
d'excitation parce qu'on avait l'air de
sortir comme ça de l'écran et c'était
vraiment un moment assez magique et puis
j'ai l'impression avec ce film avec 7,7
avant-première de thor le monde des
ténèbres en quelque sorte voilà c'est la
boucle est bouclée en quelque sorte et
c'est un vrai bonheur que de le
présenter au public français qui jouent
au courant évidemment aura beaucoup de
plaisir avec ce film vous parliez
comment est ce que j'arrive à tout faire
vous parliez quand même d'harvard d'
j'ai quand même quitté l'école et mes
études il a plus de dix ans donc
heureusement j'ai dépassé ce stade mais
c'est vrai que la vie est pleine
d'expérience de défi et je les aborde
les uns après les autres questions
autres oui j crew là bas c'est une
question pour kevin et une pour tom pour
kevin quand il ya eu la première
adaptation d'un super héros au cinéma
est ce qu'il y avait déjà tout cette
idée de lier tous les films de super
héros et pour tom est ce que c'est
toujours le même plaisir de rejouer loki
de film en film when your first dapd
alors voilà c'est vrai que lorsque nous
nous avons fait notre premier film
marvel et bien s'agissait évidemment des
x men et de spider man et là évidemment
il était impossible de penser à autre
chose puisqu'il faisait contrat
spécifique il y a également des studios
très spécifiques
en revanche dès que nous avons fait un
one man c'était notre studio nous avions
le financement nous pouvions donc amener
notre patte créative et à ce moment là
il était il est devenu évident et cool
que ce serait bien de réunir évidemment
tous ces héros et c'est vrai que
l'accueil a été formidable
j'étais très heureux surpris aussi mémé
convaincu de donc du bien aux médecins
et c'est vrai que je me suis dit après
tout c'était une façon de répliquer en
quelque sorte le plaisir qu'avaient les
lecteurs de comics de bd et pourquoi pas
à mener et faire connaître ces mêmes
héros un public différent pour qu'ils
éprouvent à son tour ce même plaisir à
me get off
oui visiting the way i s et quintéistes
justin forrest gander inde le qui est
encore aux messieurs ce et magenta avec
le temps
essam el hadary mix de 4,1 en voilà un
john murphy bowe et le mixed up his own
au moins de lavaur istomin 6 600
provocation alors notre labo et servant
globalité des émotions notamment et sa
liste grise hang seng justin qui me
ferait alors c'est vrai que je me suis
beaucoup amusé d'abord parce que en un
sens si thor et est le dieu du tonnerre
et bien évidemment l'eau qui est un peu
le dieu des deux malicieuse je dirais
donc mon job en quelque sorte c'était de
toute façon de m'amuser et je dois dire
que les directeurs avec lesquels j'ai
travaillé qu'il s'agisse de brannagh
jazz d'alentejo évidemment eh bien
chacun avait une idée bien spécifiques
quant à mon personnage et pour cette
fois en plus qu avait une épée gg très
évidemment à kevin avec cuisse mais
cette fois ci en plus j'ai eu le plaisir
supplémentaire de travailler avec
natalie portman et je dois dire que
j'adore ce personnage parce qu'il est
complètement dingue barjots et j'adore
ça d'abord parce que il a du charme
il aime s'amuser il aime provoquer mais
en même temps il est vulnérable
il a des failles émotionnel il est dans
la douleur il est dans la colère dans la
jalousie et toutes ces émotions
complexes et bien sont très
intéressantes pour un acteur autre
question bonjour c'est pour nathalie
comment s'est déroulée votre le tournage
de thor et comment comment s'est
déroulée votre collaboration avec chris
hemsworth bien sûr c'est vrai que
c'était une réunion très très joyeuse
parce qu'on s'entend évidemment tous
très bien c'est une bonne équipe et
surtout je crois que sur le tournage on
a eu beaucoup de plaisir parce qu'elle
est toute cette énergie commune que nos
amis et puis bien sûr avec allen qui a
mené son énergie propre c'était
absolument merveilleux kressh évidemment
quand dire sinon que voilà on ne peut
pas lui trouver des défauts je crois que
si vous cherchiez vous auriez beaucoup
de mal il est il est intelligent il est
drôle il est généreux il est super
talentueux
bref c'est un amour surtout comparé à
tom je plaisantais évidemment autre
question l'orientation pour alan taylor
vous nous avez dit hier soir que vous
aviez peur d'anthony hopkins
alors est ce qu'il est vraiment mauvaise
réputation à ce point là et surtout
comment ça s'est passé
lui me wade a analysé y en a une gueule
soit 1 mais on le répète est non alors
c'est vrai que lorsque je parlais un
petit peu de peur hier soir je ne
parlais pas du tout peur de sa
réputation car il a une réputation
merveilleuse mais surtout une peur parce
que je me souvenais d'avoir été frappé
non pas tant par ses rôles un peu
terrible tel que celui d'hannibal acte
bien sûr mais plutôt par le rôle qu'il
jouait dans le film de david lynch
elephant man où il ya cette phrase
formidable tout simple et essuie suis
jeune homme bon suis-je un homme mauvais
est ce cette simple phrase était si
puissante
son talent était si évident que c'est
cela que j'avais gardé à l'esprit je me
suis embrouillé fois que j'ai rencontré
petit déjeuner à berlin et bien cette
peur c'est totalement évanouie au bout
de deux minutes dans la conversation
je me suis rendu compte à quel point il
était généreux il était chaleureux avec
justement les garçons qui venaient nous
servir avec tout le monde et tout de
suite je me suis dit
tout va bien se passer et j'avoue que
sur le tournage c'était encore plus
évident ce qui s'amuse à faire des
imitations des chiens période d'agapes
choix d'un terrier voilà donc vous voyez
et à ce moment là évidemment c'est un
plaisir puisque c'est l'un des meilleurs
acteurs au monde aujourd'hui question
faut-il avoit là et ont su j'aimerais
bien qu'on passe de ce côté question
pour nathalie vous avez beaucoup de
talent comme gwyneth paltrow iron man 3
votre rôle de jeune fille en détresse
devient plus important presque centrale
dans l'histoire les fans de super héros
deviennent elles aussi voire plus
importante que le héros selon vous alors
du fil des semaines
at war alors c'est vrai que ce film
effectivement montre que marvel en tout
cas à vraiment dans son univers
l'intention de m de montrer montre
d'ailleurs les femmes et les hommes
d'une manière en quelque sorte identique
on n'a pas l'impression que les hommes
et les femmes ont des dix ont des
qualités ou des traits de caractères
différents et qu'ils soient particuliers
un genre c'est à dire que chacun hommes
aux femmes ont des qualités à la fois
positives et négatives
les deux peuvent être par certains
moments vulnérables à d'autres très fort
en même temps c'est quelque chose d'un
terne également par exemple mon
personnage
à certains moments et très vulnérable à
d'autres moments à une véritable force
donc je crois qui est intéressant
effectivement mon ses personnages de
femmes c'est qu'elles peuvent être aussi
passionné aussi drôle à voir des
carrières et je crois que c'est une
façon effectivement d'aborder la parité
au cinéma mais sans être évidemment une
espèce comme ça de dehors regardé comme
ce film est féministe non c'est pas du
tout l'idée simplement de façon réelle
dans ce film est bien les femmes je
pense à jaimie alexander je pense
évidemment rené rousseau je pense
évidemment aussi à kate dennings et bien
toute cette toutes ces femmes sont
fortes on leur personnalité et c'est en
cela je crois que c'est important que le
rôle des femmes effectivement
apparaissent ainsi semblable à celui des
hommes autre question oui bonjour c'est
une question pour tom alors on a vu
beaucoup de facettes de l'eau qui dans
les films précédents à ce fait de
pouvoir là dans le dernier il est un peu
plus trickster un peu plus drôle
j'aimerais savoir comment vous aimeriez
le voir évoluer qu'est ce qui serait le
prochain challenge à jouer comment vous
aimeriez jouer la phase aller ce match
me déçoit
ô dieu signaux mais nuke acte avec in
waiting on fame est pleine de bain et ça
change
c'est vrai que c'est une question
évidemment importante et d'ailleurs nous
en avions parlé avec alan avec russe en
réalité qu'est ce que qu'est ce que mon
personnage qu'est ce que l'eau qui veut
réellement finalement et c'est vrai que
c'est une question que l'on peut se
poser à chaque personnage que l'on
interprète mais je crois finalement que
l'eau qui ne le sait plus lui-même
il fut un temps où il avait envie d'être
l'égal de tort d'avoir évidemment
l'amour et la fierté de ses parents même
d'être roi mais je crois que dans sa
nature
il préfère finalement joué que gagner et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que on va
voir à l'avenir s'il arrive à être en
tout cas près d'une certaine forme de
victoire pour lui et c'est en cela je
crois que l'avenir de l'eau qui va se
dessiner
autre question j'en ai deux une pour le
producteur et réalisateur
en ce moment les chine dessus
héros explore beaucoup la face noire des
choses côté des ténèbres
qu'est ce qui les pousse à explorer cet
univers l'un et l'autre question que
peut-être s'adresser à tous et est ce
qu'on peut pas y voir une métaphore un
petit peu comme notre monde venant des
ténèbres et retournant pouvoir commencer
à y être aujourd'hui
amine bd must super film touche ou go to
the darkside radio explique date du
cèdre il faut à wise as we going back to
doc twitter
alors votre votre parti de votre
question je ne m'adresse pas tout ça
mais en parlant des super héros bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois on est
évidemment dans le faire semblant et à
chaque fois évidemment il faut aller
plus haut mettre la barre plus haut donc
on essaie en quelque sorte d' effacer ce
qui a précédé et on essaie de de
s'éloigner de 110 ans voilà les autres
étaient plus dans le mode comme il
fallait de la bd et nous on va être
plutôt dans la réalité et en un sens
c'est pour à nos yeux en tout cas se
rapprocher du public est un petit peu
d'ailleurs l'évolution de batman qui
n'ait pas été un caractère plutôt bd et
qui ensuite à l évolution beaucoup plus
sombre que l'on connaît je crois qu'ici
avec main vos nous sommes dit
effectivement qu'on allait aller dans un
univers plus sombre
effectivement des choses terribles
arrive à des gens formidables mais en
même temps je voulais c'est vrai un
univers plus dur plus crue plus réaliste
et en même temps un équilibre grâce
évidemment à l'humour du film et je
crois qu'effectivement ce côté d'aller
vers le côté sombre des choses c'est
avant tout une façon pour nous de nous
relier au public et là je ne sais pas si
c'est parce qu'il se sent dans un
environnement très sombre mais c'est en
tout cas notre façon de dire regardez là
on est en train de devenir sérieux et de
vous dire des vraies choses et je crois
que l'alchimie réussie par marvel c'est
justement ce mélange de réalisme très
dur et d'humour également qui établit un
équilibre qui me semble bon de ce que
oui a alors dernière question alors est
ce qu'il y avait pardonnez-moi y avait
dernière question de la question qu'un
micro c'est la station bonjour voilà
alors ce sera une question en deux
parties d'abord pour kevin épaulé pour
alan
alan est principalement connu en france
pour avoir réalisé une demi douzaine
d'épisodes de game of thrones comment la
production de marvel et a été amené à
choisir ce réalisateur est la deuxième
partie de la question ce sera pour
nathalie dans le film pour terminer plus
légèrement dans le film vous avez
l'occasion de gifler à la fois tort est
à la fois loki lequel des deux vous avez
préféré giflé et lequel des deux le
votre personnage a préféré giflé alors
voilà qui fera envie aux côtoient comme
kempen
un hymne des wôrô jouer lille i am
c'est vrai que vous parliez évidemment
du trône de fer mais allen est connu
pour bien d'autres choses
extraordinaires évidemment des épisodes
des sopranos de provoquer de mad men et
depuis toute façon dix ans à peu près la
télévision a totalement évolué dans son
dans son langage et s'inspire ou vice
versa du monde du cinéma
donc nous ce que nous cherchons à main
vous bien sûr c'est de trouver des gens
qui quelles que soient leurs univers a
priori que soit la télé haute qui ont
fait des choses extraordinaires et qui
donc comme d'ailleurs game of thrones le
trône de fer
eh bien il ya ce mélange que nous
adorons qu'elle se mélange de
fantastique et de réalisme évidemment
alors que l'homme n'a subi la loi
gayssot forme des actrices porno view
and found love you will get home insisté
ardennes alors voilà alors je veux dire
c'était très agréable de les gifler
j'avoue en fait je dirais que thor
c'était plutôt une gifle d'amour alors
que pour l'eau qui s'était plutôt une
gifle au nom finalement de tous les new
yorkais qui était fou furieux après lui
pour tout ce qu'ils avaient essayé de
leur faire
donc c'était c'était très agréable et
j'ai eu beaucoup de satisfactions et
puis évidemment torse et dg dean gifle
d'amour mais c'était aussi une gifle en
gros pour tout mais mes soeurs qui
parfois sont abandonnés et qui ne revoit
jamais leur bien-aimée donc c'était une
gifle à cet effet là en parfaite
solidarité voilà ainsi se conclut ce
cette conférence de presse et bien sûr
l'eau qui a rajouté en français vous
pouvez le dit avec zain oeil aux
frenchies great one you say i love being
told you said in french
j'aime bien
ouais recevoir à un gifle de mawazine
portman c'était c'était un plaisir et un
honneur
sheng